we have a great phrase today on the
bloomberg talking about a year of fire
and ice
the decade began really with everything
crumbling and a lot of panic
and now we're sort of heading into a new
year
when apparently nothing can go wrong
there was some feeling in the white
house that this virus was so contagious
that it was almost inevitable that
people were going to get it
for weeks and weeks china and the who
was
downplaying what was happening
there was resistance to impose a strict
lockdown
because it's one of the industrial hubs
of italy
the outbreak itself is unprecedented but
divisiveness
in which it is evolving is unprecedented
the idea back then that a vaccine would
be the way out of this
was quite crazy at the beginning
we have a totally under control it's one
person
coming in from china we have to operate
in a political context we were in
unchartered territory everything we did
was right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
2020 was a year like no other
it was a tale of government missteps
missed opportunities to contain the
virus
and mixed messaging that left many
uncertain of the risks
and divided on the cures
2021 begins with reasons for optimism
but experts see more viral threats ahead
if we have any hope to bring an end to
this pandemic in which at least 2
million are expected to die
and protect against future outbreaks we
need to understand
what went wrong with our global response
starting at the beginning
[Music]
i still remember the first time we saw a
report
actually stocks started tanking because
there was this rumor
circulating online that there was a
mysterious pneumonia
that was detected in wuhan there's
growing concern across
asia as the wuhan pneumonia outbreak
continues to spread
i'd actually just come back from wuhan
reporting on a separate story and i
still remember us
joking about good thing you didn't fall
sick and you know we hope you didn't
catch anything
in early january hospitals in wuhan
faced an onslaught of severely sick
patients
and antibiotic treatments weren't
working the local health care system
started to break down we sent a couple
of headlines and
we were kind of you know like oh
wouldn't it be crazy if there was
another sars
china has announced the first death from
an outbreak of pneumonia
caused by an unidentified virus by
january 10th
chinese scientists have mapped out the
genetic makeup of the virus that would
be shared with infectious disease
experts worldwide
at that time 41 people were diagnosed
with the virus
it was a gradual evolution and awareness
of how just how bad it could be it went
from
a curiosity to over a period of a few
months
an impending disaster within weeks the
pathogen is running riot throughout
wuhan's population of 11 million
as well as the broader central chinese
province of hubei
and then on january 23rd they
shut down wuhan and that was the moment
we knew
that it was serious
a city of 11 million people with almost
no one
on the streets people in wuhan have been
asked not to leave the city
and outsiders have been told to stay
away
it took effect at 10 am the next day
even people in wuhan didn't know what it
really meant
it's kind of difficult to get the
perspective of how
uh drastic a move that was back then
when that happened then they announced
that they were quarantining wuhan that
was pretty much
the biggest quarantine that anybody
had ever experienced in recent history
groceries were flying off the shelves
people were stocking up people were
trying to get out trying to get on the
last train
trying to drive out of the city there
was a lot of confusing information
i wanted to get my medication but this
pharmacy is closed
if this situation continues for one or
two more weeks
it'll get more complicated what took
people by surprise is that you know
the message from china for so long was
that it was not a big deal and suddenly
they escalated it
so abruptly with not laying the
groundwork with anybody
china's still uncontrolled viral
outbreak comes just ahead of the
week-long lunar new year holidays
it's the biggest annual human migration
in the world
when millions of tourists fan out across
asia and europe
public health experts feared a massive
seeding of the virus across the globe
the government prevented a lot of people
from returning to the cities after
chinese new year and that really
affected a lot of people you know they
weren't able to make money they weren't
able to
go back to their jobs and i think that
that was a really crucial moment
in just establishing the fact that we
were in uncharted territory
and that everything going on was now on
the level that
had never been experienced for a long
time
by the end of january the world health
organization declared the virus a public
health emergency
of international concern it wouldn't
call it a pandemic until march 11th
some critics fault it for being too slow
a who official said the organization had
been sounding the alarm
well before making its official call
once you label something as a pandemic
there is a tendency on the part of
certain groups of people
to shrug their shoulders and say oh no
pandemic is here
we just might as well get on and limit
the damage as much as possible
whereas the message that we all wanted
to convey
from the end of january was this is a
really
nasty virus don't underestimate it
the most challenging part of that
initial phase of the crisis
is that for weeks and weeks china
and the who was downplaying what was
happening
uhan finally admitted that was human to
human transmission but they were saying
there was not that much
who repeated that
at this point the chinese government was
under heavy criticism for not
communicating effectively with the
public releasing little information on
the size and scope of the crisis
china wanted to keep people from coming
in to investigate the origin
of the virus which is still an extremely
sensitive topic in china right now
the who was widely criticized by the
international community for praising
china
in the early stages of the pandemic but
according to the who
they had no choice people who are given
responsibility in public health
we're not able just to call the shots
all the time
we have to operate in a political
context
our colleagues in china we're dealing
with an acute problem
we're trying to collect data about that
acute problem
we're trying also to work inside the
country on
what how severe it was we're then
deciding to close down
a city of several million population
very very quickly
[Music]
a lot of china's missteps came from the
virus being so new
and no country ever having dealt with
such a situation before
china as a political system has a
tendency
towards non-disclosure and when there
is something unknown they have a
tendency to want things to be stable
to be quiet they always err on the side
of not doing anything not saying
anything
there was also a lot of information
leaking out on social media
some of that would get censored it's
very difficult to tell what was
real and what was not real public
information about the novel virus
its symptoms and level of contagiousness
were limited
some experts did try to raise the alarm
when li when liang died
he was a doctor who had warned his
former classmates and his friends
about a virus that he had heard
was spreading and had made other doctors
sick and he was saying it could be
another
sars and that everybody should take
precautions and the government
sanctioned him and other people in the
wechat group
that was really one of the moments when
it became clear to both the government
and the international community just how
much was at stake
it wasn't just about containing the
virus but it was what the virus
stood for which was whether or not the
chinese system would prevail
and whether or not all the things that
people give up
would ultimately benefit them if it
meant that their government could
contain this
deadly pandemic china was also reluctant
to let world health organization
infectious disease experts into the
country until the disease
had already spread around the globe the
who ultimately
did send a team to china but the trip
was
you know extremely tightly controlled by
the government it also
wasn't clear what china's plan was
it had shut down wuhan and had shut down
hubei
but it was still struggling to
communicate with the rest of the world
what was going on
and it hadn't shut china's borders yet
to
the rest of the world with approximately
10 000 confirmed cases of covert in
china
the trump administration uses travel
restrictions to limit the transmission
risk from china
any u.s citizen returning to the united
states
who has been in hubei province in the
previous 14 days
will be subject to up to 14 days
of mandatory quarantine the chinese
people
together with the chinese government
have gone through huge difficulties
and made great sacrifices globally china
has also fulfilled its duty of helping
control the spread
of the virus
[Music]
while wuhan would remain under strict
lockdown the virus then known officially
as sars kovi ii
had jumped to japan south korea
australia
and europe its destructive force was
keenly felt in italy
specifically its business center of
milan i went
with my kids with the kindergarten to
tell
a bunch of five years old kid what does
it mean being
a journalist and then we left in the
evening to go to my parents place which
is near venice
as soon as we got to the venice area the
number of cases
in italy had already jumped from one
to dozens and as i was going
to bed i got a whatsapp message
confirmed me
the first italian fatalities related
to coronavirus two more people had died
so that is 14 deaths
in italy and the number has also
jumped it is now more than 500. there
was resistance
to impose a strict lockdown
because it's one of the industrial hubs
of italy
some leaders were saying milan is open
for business
failure to quickly take action would
result in massive deaths at nursing
homes from a complex disease the virus
causes
called covid19 milan's hospital system
is so
overwhelmed that makeshift morgues are
required
italian prime minister giuseppe conte
pushed the world's eighth largest
economy
with more than 60 million inhabitants
into virtual quarantine
a preview of what was to come in new
york sao paulo
and mumbai we were the first western
country to face the pandemic
we no one had before an experience
so we were essentially leading the way
obviously
a green way for the rest of the western
world
even as italy locked down the virus
stormed across western europe and into
the middle east
eventually landing on american shores as
outbreaks took hold in both seattle
and new york but unlike countries like
china and south korea that took swift
and dramatic government-led action
to contain the spread of the virus
president donald trump downplays the
risk and projects confidence
that's the thing that i still don't
fully understand
is how come there was a very
clear account of what to do to get on
top of this
that came back from this joint mission
in china
what was it that led so many countries
to conclude that they would not
follow the lessons from that china
experience
and they would go about it differently
words about a pandemic at this point no
we're not at all and
we're we have it totally under control
it's one person
coming in from china and we have it
under control
it's going to be just fine he knew that
the virus could be very dangerous he'd
been told in classified briefings
that this could really rip through the
nation and kill a lot of people
jennifer jacobs is bloomberg's senior
white house reporter
he didn't want to be alarmist he didn't
want people to
stop going out and shopping and keeping
the economy moving forward
mr president happy birthday thank you
corona virus i think we're now up to our
eighth case in the united states
um how concerned are you well we pretty
much shut it down
coming in from china we can't have
thousands of people coming in who may
have
this problem the corona virus
on february 5th as cases began to show
in the united states
the cdc would send testing kits to labs
around the country
however soon after those kits would
ultimately prove to have a faulty
component
delaying widespread testing in the us
until march
and allowing the virus to spread
undetected and new york city would be
the hardest hit
early on i am an attending physician
at the mount sinai queens hospital we
had over 60 patients
waiting for a hospital bed i'm seeing
young patients old patients people of
all
age ranges who are just incredibly sick
i can't imagine my family being here
with no one so if i have to hold their
hand while they pass away
at least somebody's there you know
cities around the u.s moved to lockdowns
to control the spread
and prevent hospital systems from
becoming overwhelmed
he started off with these press
briefings back in in march where he was
telling the public
about the coronavirus and what they
should do we continue to marshal every
resource at america's disposal in the
fight against the chinese virus
the president really thrives in front of
the camera it's one of his favorite
things to do
and there was a window of time when he
really had the nation's attention
we're at war in a true sense we're at
war but one of his
strengths in front of the camera is that
he likes to ad-lib i would like you to
speak to the medical doctors to see if
there's any way that you can
apply light and heat
to cure and again i say maybe you can
maybe you can't i'm not a doctor
but i'm like a person that has a good
you know what
in public health those officials say if
you don't have
one message one unified message you
don't have any message
there were a lot of instances where the
government just sent
mixed signals what i saw not working
well
during this pandemic was communication
and public health messaging
it's very clear that we
need a clear authoritative voice
that we trust that can unite
us as a country and that can guide us
with the best
scientific evidence but scientific
evidence can change
and a lack of clear and consistent
messaging from the white house
would contribute to face masks becoming
a divisive political symbol
back in january the cdc was saying
healthy people do not need to wear masks
the us surgeon general in fact tweeted a
message
in which he said seriously people stop
buying masks
but then as we learn more about the
virus we realized
that you know up to 45 of patients can
be infected
not have any symptoms but be
transmitting that virus
in the respiratory droplets and that was
the point when we said
wait a minute then mask makes sense
right
let everyone wear a mask so that if
they're infected then that will contain
those respiratory droplets
and keep them from transmitting the
virus to other people
we were in an evolving situation and
when an evolving
unrolling situation is in effect your
information
will evolve and you'll be able to make
decisions
based on the most recent information
the cdc in early april put out guidance
to wear masks
however trump would emphasize it being a
personal choice
one he often said no to i think wearing
a face mask
as i greet presidents prime ministers
dictators kings queens i don't know
somehow
i don't see it for myself and while
health officials and even democratic
rival joe biden would emphatically
support masks
trump would continue to avoid being seen
in public wearing one
if you are on the left of the political
spectrum you're probably
very concerned about health care that's
probably one of your top issues if
you're on
the right side of the ideology maybe
your
top concerns are about foreign policy or
about the economy so there was
this innate divide from the beginning
about
what exactly should be the top priority
and the president
just never really um felt that masks
were going to be a panacea and just
never really encouraged
them and people especially his
supporters really
adopted that and that became baked into
the public psyche that masks were not
necessarily
what they should be doing
can't you breathe
by mid-april state and local
stay-at-home orders have fueled a
devastating
economic impact for many americans in
the harshest downturn for american
workers in history
employers cut 20.5 million jobs
pushing the jobless rate to nearly 15
percent
[Music]
and even though congress would pass the
2.2 trillion dollar cares act
the largest economic recovery package in
history
large-scale rallies would erupt all
around the country
we've had enough so we're practicing
what you see is our right to express our
heartfelt feelings
we want to get back to work trump would
show support for these rallies tweeting
liberate michigan
liberate minnesota and virginia it's an
extraordinary fact
that he is siding with these
anti-lockdown activists
and not with his own scientific advisors
so what do i say to the science i say i
don't believe your science because i
believe my god
the denial of reality because authority
tells you something
it's it's stunning truly surprised me
the depth and the extent of it we have a
historic pandemic
that's ravaging the world and in our
country and not we're not alone some of
the european countries
are the same there's a degree of
political divisiveness
that a public health issue has
assumed strong political overtones
namely you are one ideology you believe
one thing another ideology you believe
in other
masks work masks don't work it's a hoax
it's real it's just extraordinary
going through this right now i think is
unprecedented
[Music]
there was some feeling in the white
house that this virus was so contagious
that it was almost inevitable that
people were going to get it and
at some point the trump administration
decided that the best message was
let's just wait for this vaccine in late
april
bloomberg breaks news of operation warp
speed
a manhattan project-style u.s
government-led effort to drastically cut
the time needed to develop a vaccine
the project's goal was to have 300
million doses of a covet vaccine by
january 2021
the trump administration absolutely
deserves
a lot of credit for operation warp speed
i mean the amount of money that was
poured in
by the administration was extraordinary
billions
and billions of dollars through
operation warp speed
the us had a war chest of 18 billion to
invest in covert 19
vaccines and treatments the idea back
then that a vaccine would be the way out
of this was a really difficult thing to
comprehend
because if you look at the timelines it
takes to get vaccines
developed and you know the majority of
which are not even successful but it can
take around a decade
to get a successful vaccine to market so
the idea that you could get a vaccine in
a sort of 12 to 18 month time frame that
would be sufficient
to help the world emerge from this
pandemic was
quite crazy at the beginning
[Music]
in late spring early summer you saw a
number of countries like the uk the us
and the european union particularly
step up and create programs that would
allow them to accelerate the development
of the vaccines and also
fund the vaccines on a wide-ranging
platform to give multiple shots on goal
for their countries those regions to
have something successful
we saw similar efforts in china and in
russia with their own national vaccines
that they were trialing and investing in
and funding for their populations
in the past worldwide vaccine
development was starved for funding
big pharma and biotech firms usually
focus on more lucrative areas like
cancer treatments
from spring to summer a number of
vaccines would begin trials
particularly promising with vaccines
using a new technology called messenger
rna
being developed by moderna and the
pfizer biontech partnership
we get this little piece of messenger
rna which is relatively unstable
that's why we have to keep it frozen we
have this messenger rna deliver the
message
that the cells need so that then we can
mount a response
to this virus and then it's destroyed
and even though its timeline was
slightly behind other leading candidates
a vaccine being developed by oxford
scientists and drug maker astrazeneca
would get a lot of early attention the
astrazeneca oxford vaccine
has really had an outsized impact on
supply agreements because not
only can it be stored at refrigerator
conditions which makes it much more
conducive
um to be deployed to the developing
world
but it also is going to be sold at cost
during the period of the pandemic which
makes it much more feasible for
countries
to purchase huge doses of the vaccine so
when you're thinking about which horse
to back astrazeneca oxford was a really
good bet at the beginning of the
pandemic for both success
deployment cost and just the potential
to be really effective in ending the
pandemic
as scientists rush to develop a vaccine
a summer surge of cases emerges
worldwide
any hope that warmer weather would tame
the virus is dashed
as it continued its rampage across
europe and the developing world
particularly india brazil and south
africa
however china's strict lockdowns have
allowed for life to return to
normal for many citizens back in the
united states
while cases in the northeast stabilized
premature lifting of lockdowns caused a
spike of cases in the sunbelt
and by september midwest states
experienced a dramatic
rise in covert 19 cases with south
dakota alone having a 166
increase and 10 other states reporting
record one-day increases
the annual sturgis motorcycle rally
school and university reopenings
and labor day weekend celebrations have
all been cited as case links
yet nobody was quite expecting a viral
outbreak in the west wing of the white
house
when i heard that hope hicks one of the
president's closest advisors
had the virus we immediately started
thinking
it's possible that the president had it
word has come that one of president
trump's closest aides
hope hicks has tested positive for
coronavirus and in fact
is apparently quite sick the
fact that we reported on hope's illness
sent a signal to the white house
that we've got deep sourcing that they
probably can't hide this from us
that no matter what happens someone is
going to find out
and i know that people think that there
was a good chance that if we hadn't
reported on hope hicks's
diagnosis that it's possible we never
would have known about the president's
diagnosis
the president of the united states now
confirming to the world that he
and the first lady of the united states
have both tested positive
for the coronavirus and they will
quarantine
president trump received dexamethasone
rome deserve
and a cocktail of therapeutic antibodies
from drug maker regeneron
that was not yet available to the public
at the same time
more officials were testing positive
breaking news but it's fair to say there
is an
outbreak within the white house
kellyanne conway has tested positive
for the coronavirus governor chris
christie now reports
that he has tested positive stephen
miller a senior aide to president trump
has become the 24th person
connected to the white house to test
positive for covet 19.
there was a very much worry about it
spreading throughout the entire west
wing
there was worry about his re-election
prospects there was worry
about how this was going to affect their
entire plan
until the november third election but
after several days in walter reed
president trump would be released and
would return to the white house
walking out on his own this image
already getting attention back at the
white house tonight appearing eager
to take off that mask and signaling
tonight he'll be back at the campaign
trail soon
[Music]
however just a little over a month later
in a record-breaking election turnout
trump would lose to democratic
challenger joe biden here's your final
tally
in the electoral college this is for the
history books wolf 306 electoral votes
for joe biden
232 electoral votes for donald trump
as you noted that is an exact reversal
of what it was four years ago
his advisors do know that
the handling of the coronavirus by the
the white house and by the president
himself and his refusal to model some of
the public health measures that
could have at least put a dent in in the
coronavirus probably killed his
re-election
as trump's legal team aggressively
challenged the election's outcome
there were huge developments on the
vaccine front on november 9th the pfizer
biontech
vaccine reported to show a more than 90
efficacy rating
a week later modernist vaccine would
report 94.5
efficacy i was saying boy i'll take a
70 percent effective vaccine 65
effective vaccine it will be very
helpful
it won't crush the outbreak but it'd be
very helpful
to get 95 effective vaccines
from two candidates that
were the same platform but different
companies
with essentially identical results 94 95
percent efficacy
i was overwhelmingly pleasantly
surprised
that that was the case so that's the one
thing i did not predict
[Music]
in the first week of december the uk was
the first to clear the use of a new shot
from pfizer inc and beyond tech essay
the us would do the same a week later
the approval of modernist vaccine would
follow later in the month
not long after people aged 80 and over
in the uk
began receiving the vaccine the uk as
the first doses of the chronovaccine are
being injected into patients the
country's
mass national vaccination program has
officially
begun and to put this into context this
comes less than a year
after the first case of covet 19.
vaccines being shipped to health care
workers came as a welcome relief
as the us death toll surpasses 325 000
global deaths top 1.7 million and
reports of a new variant out of the uk
show some mutations that appear to make
the virus even more contagious
by the end of 2020 millions of people
were expected to be inoculated
by the end of 2021 public health
officials in some countries aim to have
60
to 70 percent of their populations
immunized
yet skeptics say that may be a challenge
i think we're going to be far
short of the vaccine we're going to need
in the first two to three quarters of
next year in the united states i think
that's still going to be a challenge
there's the logistics and distribution
then there's finding the money
then there's all the coordination it's
just a big job
and having seen the challenges that
world leaders
have faced in actually dealing
just simply with the infection and
trying to find a way to
work on the infection uh i'm thinking
they will also face challenges with the
immunization
and even if the rollout of the vaccine
in the u.s and the world goes swimmingly
it brings up an entirely new problem i
think we have kind of a double-edged
sword challenge
of early on we're going to have many
early adopters that want the vaccine
and we're not going to have nearly
enough which is going to create its own
crisis
followed by what i'm afraid will be
vaccines sitting there waiting to find
an arm
about a quarter of americans do not want
to get vaccinated
the skepticism represents a challenge as
the country
tries to control exploding infections
hospitalizations and deaths
many are wary of the vaccine's
unprecedented speed
others are polarized by politics
the depth of the scientific hostility to
science
anti-science which spills over into
anti-vaxx
truly surprised me there are certain
regions of the country where in the very
towns counties cities
where the hospitals are being overrun
with covet 19
patients there are people in that area
which are still
saying it's a hoax it's fake news it
doesn't exist
it's mind-boggling to see that the us
and uk have reserved enough vaccines to
inoculate between 150 percent
and nearly 300 percent of their
population
but poorer countries like vietnam
ukraine and uganda
so far only have enough allocated to
them to cover about five percent of
their populations
under an international vaccine
acquisition group
i want to ask all world leaders
to ask themselves are they viewing this
from a truly
international perspective or are they
viewing it
from a parochial national perspective
ultimately the impact of kovib will be
felt for years to come
and how leaders around the world not
only learn from this past
year but prepare in future years will
determine the extent of the next
outbreak
it's not if but when the next pandemic
occurs
we do understand how it how important it
is to be prepared
and hopefully we'll take the necessary
steps to be prepared
we need to push the science and we need
to follow
scientific advice we we need to to learn
to
trust our public health officials and we
need to have that united voice moving
forward
so that hopefully in future pandemics we
won't be
divided as a country
while many things went wrong throughout
the year when it comes to covid there
are still victories that warrant
cautious optimism i think one of the
things that we did do
right was getting a vaccine
you know into patients i am totally
impressed by the way in which scientists
everywhere
have cooperated like never before on the
vaccination
and also honestly i want to say that the
the companies have done pretty well
too we will need a lot more of that kind
of radical collaboration
for the vaccination process not only do
we have to continue doing what we've
done
but we have to actually redouble our
efforts
to stretch our collaboration potential
for the sake of the future of humanity
quite honestly
[Music]
you